things to think about for your social
media page are making sure you follow
the guidelines for each platform make
sure you have all the things like a
cover photo a profile photo and a
description and make sure that you have
a tone of voice for your brand and
you're sticking to it you want your
company to have a voice and a
personality that's recognizable by your
customers because you already know your
market segments or your persona you'll
know how to communicate with them now if
it's relevant to your audience try to be
a little bit light-hearted and delight
your user in a funny way Mike user
smiled from the way you communicate with
them MailChimp lets you have a little
bit of fun when you're setting up your
account if you try to choose a username
that already exists they say maybe it's
your evil twin spooky you kind of get
their personality through that and it's
delightful and it'll make you smile if
you notice it check out read me when
you're about to put in your password the
little owl covers up his eyes it's a
cute little extra touch once you have
your basic setup in your unique tone of
voice all you have to do is simply find
the secret sauce to make your content go
viral easy right well no it's actually
the most challenging thing with social
media it's really hard to predict what
your audience will share and what
they're really going to engage with
hopefully you'll measure everything you
do and be able to learn from it if your
app is great users will spread the word
for you you should make it easy for
users to share by adding a social
feature to your app google recently
launched app invites which will allow
your users to easily share your app with
their contacts app invites will
recommend your users their closest
contacts to share your app with and give
them an easy to download link right in
an email or text message you see this a
lot with game apps where your users are
given an image to share on Twitter with
their highest score or their ranking in
the game you can also see this in
shopping apps when they recommend that
you post what you just bought to
Facebook let's get them experts advise
on social media